na na na na non stop et miniplexe maison
dans la prairie
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt sa part contre
le lait il y à un toujours de là dans la
région il ya environ 900 producteurs de
lait et tous les jours ils ont la visite
de ce camion c'est le collecteur 460
millions de litres de lait sont tous les
ans livré à l'industrie en centre val de
loire s'en fait des briques seul et tout
frais est amené à la laiterie
on vous parle souvent de lactalis et
compagnie mais dans la région il reste
quelques irréductibles les tripes
grâce à elle vous trouvez dans vos
rayons des briques comme ça c'est qui le
patron c'est le consommateur puisque
c'est lui qui a fixé le prix de la
brique à 99 centimes
cerise sur le gâteau le producteur et
payer juste prix et en plus les les
médecines chez nous
[Musique]